billionaire businessman Jeffrey Epstein
was arrested in New York Saturday on
federal charges related to sex
trafficking so there's two grand
conspiracies here the child sex
trafficking conspiracy who was
responsible for that criminal operation
and is also the conspiracy in the murder
of Jeffrey Epstein to go from being a
schoolteacher to being a billionaire in
that amount of time he's clicked up with
the financial mafia he's doing bad bad
evil favors for these people he's
filming elites such as Prince Andrew
with underage girls having them
photographed so he's got the goods on
them I was around 18 Epstein and II
approximately eight other young girls
and I had sex together so even though
she was 18 and it's not an offense
she is witnessing other minor children
in this orgy with Prince Andrew this is
the worst scandal to hit the royal
family yeah Epstein had the pedophile
Island he also had the Lolita Express a
plane with a bed so it was out of any
legal jurisdiction it's flying around
he's got the victims trap you know in
the into the sky basically on this plane
and the girls were servicing the
customers Bill Clinton is the
sexual-assault cocaine had rapist
vilandra he was on the Lolita Express
what was it 26 times disgrace financier
Jeffrey Epstein has taken his own life
while he was behind bars here in New
York City if Epstein would have lived
unlisted the gun into the court system
all that stuff would have been looked at
that's why Epstein had to go because the
people that would have led - so this is
the book of contacts that was taken by
the police and is in the court system as
legal discovery for these cases a very
bad guy if he's got you in his booth all
right there's a chance you're not
involved but it isn't a good look is it
there's a lot of wealthy people in here
powerful people it's amazing how many
[Music]
shut up can you sort this podcast by
saying shut out or cameraman shut out
well edited these guys kill it every
thank you guys and now on the true
Geordie podcast we have the return of
the king of crying podcast it's good see
again Shaun hated Ellen our brothers
love and respect to have me back on you
guys lip my channel up I had 10,000 subs
came on true Jodi got almost 300,000
subs now it's just non-stop and it's all
it's all two years it's not we we sort
of push you in the right direction but
you smashed it me it's a well done I had
that channel for ten years Brian guys
came along I've got to admit that seeing
them because we've had a few people
quite a lot what I like to help
youtubers will I see potential in and
we've had people from bluevine mind
braudy we've had all sorts of people
from all different yeah I love helping
people who deserve it
and you you deserve a me so you've done
all of this research you've even brought
all these papers with you we're gonna
talk about some of the stuff you've been
researching lately I'm excited not
really enjoyed was when Sean sat down he
had this massive stack of papers and he
just went wild man calls me the robot
right okay yeah but that's just because
what man is so wild but anyone goes on
it we will we will get a wild man again
cuz I'm gonna give the people what they
want more there's so much been going on
on your channel I just want to actually
law that we see you it has been so good
recently Saints Brian the other day I
enjoyed you going through Epstein's
little black we'll start with Epstein
yeah this guy Jeffrey Epstein has been
in all the papers as as David Icke would
say a perfect cure of victims and 44 his
pals who you and I don't have any idea
why we're gonna find out got sent a list
of all of these people who were in his
black book of contacts
like let's start with who is Jeffrey
Epstein to start off with all right just
a little bit about our concepts then
then so on my prison questions playlist
people are constantly sending me like
what's the latest on you know Weinstein
our Epstein so far I need to just do a
video on Epstein
I looked into it and I've been right in
the book American made about the
Clintons about a [__] on the side and
all those people that the Clintons are
knocked up over the years when you say
knocked off yeah do you mean like not
like as in you know Frank Underwood on
house of cards when he like knocks
people yeah yeah absolutely I've got the
Clintons down as the clinton crime
family down is one of the most homicidal
in the history of American politics we
play all right we are talking about Bill
and Hillary Hillary is actually word for
it it's Arkin side and in the dictionary
it's called the favorite method of
getting rid of political enemies in the
state of Arkansas when the medical
examiners explain away two bodies filled
with bullets as a case of suicide
it's obvious they caught a case of
Arkansas and it gives the example
Hillary Clinton threatened Barack Obama
with ARC aside last Friday or Vince
Foster was found dead in Fort Macy Park
clearly it was a case of Arkansas
Arkansas days as of another word for
clear murder that no one acknowledges is
in there but probably the Clintons are
responsible for instance specifically
them within a conspiracy of others I was
led to this conclusion writing the book
America may because it's about this
pilot Barry seal who's a CIA cocaine
smuggling pilot he's bringing all this
cocaine from Central and South America
into Manor Arkansas there was a Tom
Cruise was in the movie yes so the CIA
are getting run by George HW Bush at
this point in time and Oliver North and
they are the federal people in charge of
this operation but the State Police was
controlled by Governor Bill Clinton it
was the governor of Arkansas at that
time so the Clinton and Bush crime
families were working together
to bring this cocaine into the country
and then they were sending weapons South
to Nicaragua now two boys were out and
just to put a bit a little bit onto that
yeah Bill Clinton was literally so it
was George Bush Senior their dad yeah
then Bill Clinton then George Bush jr.
if I'm writing yes so they really kept
that country in the families for good
what was it
eighteen years something like twelve
years at least some wave work together
and if you look at the last election
George HW Bush Republican actually voted
for Hillary Clinton mmm
so I started my new book out which is
called we are being lied to the war on
drugs hopefully I'll be out for
Christmas with the story of put that on
your slamming Christmas trees with the
story of the boys on the tracks so Don
Henry and Kevin Ives were out in the
woods and they saw one of these drug
drops and then they were apprehended by
the people protecting the drug drops
which was sanctioned by Clinton Clinton
was in charge of the security the State
Police next day these boys have found
side by side on railway tracks with a
tarp over them run over by a train so
the medical examiner dr. Malik who
worked for Clinton would not kick this
guy out no matter what his rulings ruled
but Don Henry and Kevin Ives had smoked
so much weed together they'd gone into
this psychedelic trance lay side by side
on the railway tracks and the train had
run over them how high would you have to
be so high that they considerately
covered themselves in tarp yeah so these
are on the list of clinton body count
remember trump tweeted clinton body
count a week over the epstein thing so
this is how the Epstein thing links back
to the Clintons and just to give you
some examples of dr. Malik briefly here
some of these other rulings with the
public outraged by the injustice and
stonewalling of dr. Malik the media
investigated his track record in 1982 a
man's body was found with five bullet
wounds which Malik ruled a suicide in
1985 a north Arkansas man was fatally
shot
Malik ruled
a suicide even though the victim had
four shotgun wounds to the chest in 1986
he ruled accidental drowning in a case
of a victim who had been shot in the
head when a depressed patient was found
hung in the shower of a hospital he
ruled it a suicide all this is going to
tie into Epstein in a minute when the
wife sued the hospital for negligence
he changed the cause of death to an
accident that had happened during a
voluntary act of strangulation and
masturbation designed to increase sexual
pleasure
that's the asphyxia one cousin it yeah
and we we've all heard of it in excess
his most far-fetched ruling was that of
James Milam who dr. Malak claimed had
died from all set related natural causes
when Milam skull was recovered it was
determined that he'd been decapitated
with a sharp knife must have been a
really bad also that to do that yeah
ulcers do develop knives so this guy
basically it seems is is being anytime
someone goes missing or something
happens it the clintons go yeah can you
wear can you do the coroner job on that
and just make sure this goes away
exactly okay yeah so the trajectory of
this extends all the way it's the
Epstein right is he involved in Epstein
this doctor at all no this doctors not
but this is a marathon if you look at
Epstein now his function for the elites
Bill Clinton when he was governor of
Arkansas he had a similar guy he worked
with called Dan Lassiter he was a
financial guy he sold bonds and they
were washing up to a hundred million
dollars a month of cocaine money through
something Bill Clinton had set up called
a DFA and when you say washing you mean
making it legal making it look like it's
legal we set up a company called
Arkansas Development Finance Authority
adver and they put this money through ad
for and then people would apply to get
loan Samantha let's get along yes give
Hillary Clinton's law firm $50,000 as
part of the scheme and then these loans
were made out you know huge loans and
they were never repaid so that's how
they wash the money the banks in
Arkansas at this time
became full of cash and a lot of the
cash were sent down to banks in Florida
as well so this is how a method that
Bill Clinton is employed even prior to
the time that he was president he had a
sidekick Dan Lassiter Dan Laster was
handing out cocaine to underage girls
and I'm getting these testimonies from
police who protected Clinton at the time
and also Larry Nichols who worked for
the Clintons
in ad fur these all these guys have
blown the whistle on this so Dan
Lassiter Clinton's sidekick money
laundering he was handing out cocaine to
underage girls and doing similar things
to what Epstein was doing Roger Clinton
Bill Clinton's brother was arrested
buying cocaine and I've listened to the
audio of that and he's using the n-word
he's using the n-word all the way
through it and he's saying you know my
brother bill some of this is for him
he's got a nose like a vacuum cleaner
and all this stuff because of a nasal
problem
hay fever because damage to his nose he
was hospitalized
hillary went down to the hospital and
told all the staff if any of this ever
gets out nasal septum damage from
cocaine abuse it was if any of this gets
out all your careers are gonna be
completely ruined so I learned all of
this from writing about these this war
on drugs series of books and it's up to
this very dark place and Epstein's just
got all the hallmarks of this Clinton
methodology right so he was involved
with the Clintons and that is sort of
the worst kept secret at this point at
what point did we see these two worlds
collide so where and what just to go
back a bit
where's Epstein in all of this how did
he start his career and where did he
come from okay let's just briefly go
over Epstein's history then so he was
born in 1953 in New York City in
Brooklyn and his mom was a school aid
than a homemaker his third work for the
New York City Department of Parks and
Recreation as a groundskeeper in Gardner
and then Jeffrey Epstein started working
in September 1974 as a physics and math
teacher at a private school for
teenagers now a lot of peda files they
will try and work in the schools or get
access to
it's incur homes and stuff like that he
was working at this Dalton school on the
Upper East Side of Manhattan
now the headmaster who hired him and
this is how incestuous this is all going
to get as the conspiracy gets described
more that the headmaster who hired him
is Donald Barr the father of Attorney
General William Barr who is presently in
charge of the investigation into
Epstein's death Wow
yeah so he was fired in 1976 from the
school for poor performance now then he
joined burst urns so when I was a
stockbroker in the 1990s in America
I was with Joseph Charles and we cleared
fruit birthstones
burst urns is one of the powerhouse
brokerage outfits but they went out of
business lay around because of all that
the loan stuff the the corruption and
the fraud on the loan stuff so Epstein
in 1976 he is a low-level junior
assistant to a floor trader so you may
have seen those old school you know
videos of the floor traders and stuff
it's all computerized these days was
that like when basically wolf of Wall
Street when he first walks in and
they're like you are nothing keep
dialing and all that [__] well that's
like the floor for the tele sales
operation no that is the floor traders
are all shouting out prices and stuff
like that we had gates in it yeah doing
all these little weird hand signals that
looked kind of cool at the time yeah so
he swiftly moved up to become an options
trader now I also started trading
options when I was a teenager and when I
was in the stock market I got the
license for options and options are if a
sure is going to go up 10% an option
will go up a hundred percent right all
you'll lose all your money immediately
so it's highly geared trading and the
thing that woke me up to 9/11 was before
the planes hit the buildings in the days
before the options trading on the ur
line stocks and all the companies
related that were going to go down the
options trading went completely off the
scale that was headline news at the time
in America and they said look the only
people who could have known this were
the terrorists this is a case of insider
terrorist
reading these trades will be traced and
we'll get these guys and it completely
disappeared out the news years later I'm
in prison reading a david icke book
Alice in Wonderland about 9/11 and he'd
done research on it and he found out
that those trades were tracked back to
an investment bank chairman of the
investment bank was ex-cia so it was all
completely linked to the CIA and it all
comes back to David Icke so at that
point I knew that the game was rigged
you know people knew it was coming mmm
there's no way those trades would have
gone through otherwise you think some
people just also got lucky in sort of
when oh well that's looking good I'll
get that because the average daily
volume on these options trades let's say
it was a thousand contracts for like the
past five years a thousand contracts it
suddenly went up to like 20,000 50,000
contracts a day what I'm seeing days
higher and higher until it happened Wow
it was so abnormal and such a multiple
there was just no way it could have been
by accident but that's almost hiding in
plain sight isn't it what the feds did
then was they went to everybody who had
knowledge of those trades and deputized
them all after getting statements and
what that means if you deputize someone
if they speak to anyone else about it
they go to prison right Wow
so back to epsteen epsteen epsteen work
is within these place so he's learning
the ropes of the financial world and
he's rising not fast because his
intelligent guy give him that and in
finance he was intelligent let's put it
that way which existed clients in
recovering stolen money this is by 1981
now he formed his own consulting firm
intercontinental assets group he
described himself as a high-level bounty
hunter then he started to brag to people
that he was an intelligence agent now
when Epstein got his first sweetheart
deal when he first got arrested for
these allegations and accusations he
ended up pleading guilty to soliciting
prostitution for underage girls which
was the sweetheart deal so the fact that
they let him off the hook at that time
is what upset
of the victims because they were
basically labeled as prostitutes if you
if you criminalize victims as
prostitutes then the testimony is going
to be no good in court but we're gonna
get to this later on on the on the when
the case reignites again so he met
Wexner Leslie Wexner Sherman and CEO of
brands the limited the founder of
Victoria's Secrets basically was one of
his big backers financial backers this
guy's got way more money than Epstein so
this isn't just a conspiracy with
Clinton this has got multiple elite
people Prince Andrew the royal family
it's one of the biggest names but I've
got the unredacted black book here we
couldn't I could show you some of those
names and I'm yeah later on so now he's
got his own gig
he's got Wexner as this financial backer
and then in March 2005 this is when the
police start to get information about
him a woman contacted Florida's Palm
Beach Police Department and alleged that
her 14 year old stepdaughter had been
taken to Epstein's mansion by an older
girl there she was allegedly paid $300
to strip and massage Epstein
she had allegedly undressed but left the
encounter wearing her underwear so he
was operating out of a range of
properties the two most famous ones are
his pedophile Island which is little st.
James in the US Virgin Islands and then
we've also got the property in New York
77 million dollar property how did is
all of this money come from all of all
of the work that we're hearing about
before this then yeah but that's an
insane amount of money to go from being
a schoolteacher from a modest background
to being a billionaire in that amount of
time he's clicked up with the financial
mafia yeah and when I described what Dan
Lassiter was doing for Bill Clinton
earlier I believe Epstein was performing
that function to the elite so this isn't
just from playing the stock market and
this is this he's doing bad bad evil
famous for these people what are the
biggest sources of income in the world
for these people
drugs and weapons and that's what these
guys that's the money that they launder
in these operations because it ties into
the Intelligence Agency so this is he's
laundering money he's not necessarily
dealing in literally dealing in drugs
and weapons he's just helping them I
believe that over the years he's getting
into more illegal schemes with drug
money a major source a blackmail scheme
whereby he's filming elites such as
Prince Andrew with underage girls and
having them photographed so he's got the
goods on them they're just two of the
strands of the enterprise because is
there's not a paper trail for this level
of money that he he got in it's like an
island
it doesn't surely add up to the amount
of money that he would have made playing
if Epstein had have lived and this had
to gone into the court system all that
stuff would have been looked at her
that's why Epstein had to go because the
people yeah that would have led to also
because I suppose if you're if you're
blackmailing a prince or someone like
that then that would mean the people
around the Prince know about the
problems as well and then that becomes a
bigger problem for the royal family for
example well let's just get into the
royal family because this is some of the
juiciest stuff that people are okay
going the most insane about online now
the breaking news last night the main
victim Virginia Roberts who's been the
most on camera about this and she's
she's very brave coming out of all this
stuff she just went on NBC's Dateline
last night this was breaking news in the
media in this country she's talking
about her sexual acts with Prince Andrew
hmm and here's what she said we went out
to club [__]
Prince Andrew got me alcohol it was in
the VIP section I'm pretty sure it was
vodka he was like let's dance I was like
okay we leave club [__] and I hop in
the car with ghilane that's ghilane
Maxwell that was Jeffrey Epstein's madam
that's the one whose house I visited and
filmed in London when you say madam does
that mean she was helping with the
handling of these people
she was procuring girls she was
orchestrating the
mid scheme and she was participating in
orgies raping underage girls which
strap-ons
and engaging in threesomes with Epstein
and his elites and associates yeah so I
hopped in the car with ghilane and
Jeffrey ghilane says he's coming back to
the house and I want you to do for him
what you do for Epstein referring to
Prince Andrew she then said they went
back to Colleen's townhouse where she
and Prince Andrew had sex in the
bathroom and then in the bedroom he
wasn't rude or anything about it he said
thank you and some kind of soft
sentiments like that and left do we know
do we know how all this woman was at the
time when Andrew allegedly had sex in
America she was on the rage under
American law
she got indoctrinated in this world when
she was about 14 or 15 and she had
Andrew over a period of time so she'd
been involved with Epstein as well and
she was basically found by this madam
and brought in to basically please these
horrible bastards please these horrible
bastards here's what she said on
Dateline
Prince Andrew started licking my toes
between my toes the arches of my feet I
couldn't believe it that even royalty
were involved and I've got more about
what she said about Prince Andrew here
this was our original statement on the
one of the lawsuits so Epstein made me
have sex with Andrew several times we
are shown in the photograph below so the
famous photograph his arm around there
he's got his arm around her and there
was speculation as to where that
photograph was taken oh we went to the
house for those who don't know you've
seen that photograph and you thought it
would be in the the house of was
Epstein's house it what we hoped it was
gonna be in ghilane Maxwell's house in
London huh so we were you to the door
didn't you and we knocked and rang and
nobody answered and as across the street
we're still filming the doors open the
cameras like the doors don't think it
over they go over so I run over and I
start talking to the maid and I can see
the madness then I'm my camera man's
like there's on me and I get about us to
get the madness to get behind me is
right there the white banister so we
confirmed that
drew was in their house for that
instance all everything that she's
saying has been I mean it it's not
provable but it added a lot of weight
with the fact that you've went and
confirmed that they were there together
any help and what side he added even
more weight as a statement from the
other victims which I can get to as well
about Andrew so here's what she said
originally I had sex with Andrew three
times including one orgy I knew he was a
royal but I called him Andy
one day was out and I was in London this
is the townhouse I got news from Maxwell
that I will be meeting a prince epstein
Tommy it was a major Prince and I needed
to exceed everything I had been taught I
was to give Andrew whatever he wanted to
make sure he got it Andrew arrived with
security guards they went out of the
house have stayed out front in the car
it was just Epstein Maxwell and me
inside alone with Andy I was introduced
to him and we kissed formally cheek to
cheek there was a lot of discussion
about Andy with his ex-wife and his
ex-wife Fergie then Maxwell said guess
how old she is
and Prince Andrew guessed 17 then they
went to club [__] then there was the
foot licking he's really about the foot
look in the sky I don't know about you
but I'm like at this point is really
just even more disgusted but not because
of the foot looking now the foot
leggings fine it's obviously the the
reality of what the reality was footing
with it was an adult who's fully into it
good luck to you but this is disgusting
generally the fact that these people are
getting brought in by the frame idea and
it's it's
Ike's been saying this for [__]
decades and he will emailed it like do
you know what I mean on this whether you
agree with David Icke on a lot of his
other theories whatever he [__]
nailed it on this thought there's no one
can take that away if it's their level
of exploitation which kind of is quite
yeah awful like where you know I don't
know I'm sort of imagining nights where
I'm going to adult friends houses as a
kid and thinking how safe I felt how
nice it was to be able to go for dinner
with someone to be able to go out and
have a good time and these people are
literally exploiting kids and like you
said though that the weird thing is is
the care the carelessness of them the
confidence of them that that's coming
through a you're paying our few and
quit like you know at the level of risk
that these people were facing they felt
untouchable clearly where it say our
fear and acquit not like like if you're
gonna keep this hush like they're not
taking the precautions at all they're
just being so whatever about it it's
called a Leith D Lance and they're so
powerful they know they're untouched so
they'll do anything huh when these guys
start to get caught in things and there
are lawsuits I don't know if you've
watched is it untouchable the Harvey
Weinstein yeah that's how I haven't seen
that no well there's parallels with
Epstein and Weinstein's or the Steen's
when the victims first get lawyers and
then the lawyers contact these guys they
just send them hundreds of thousands of
dollars if not millions as settlements
and have them sign non-disclosure
agreements yeah what Michael Jackson did
it with his first victim as well now
you'd think after that had happened a
few times you'd be like okay I've need
to stop doing this you know this is a
crime these women are getting upset and
paying out all this money but no they
look at it like I can just pay these
people off and keep doing it it just
gets worse and worse so it's a sickness
it really is so to continue with
Virginia Roberts statement so the day
after the foot licking she told Epstein
that it went great an Epstein said you
did well the prints had fun I felt like
I was being graded it was horrible to
have to recount all these events and
have to try to meet all these needs and
once
I told Epstein about Andy's sexual
interests in feet
Epstein thought it was very funny he
appeared to be collecting private
information about Andy this is part of
the blackmail scheme yeah he wants to
know every single thing you asked for
doesn't he contain literally I dare he's
gonna use it
when I got back from the trip Epstein
paid me more than he had paid me to be
with anyone else
approximately fifteen thousand dollars
that money was for what I had done and
to keep my mouth shut about working with
the prints the second time I had sex
with Prince Andrew was in Epstein's New
York mansion in spring 2001 I was 17
Epstein called me down to his office
when I got there Epstein was the
with Maxwell Johanna Solberg that's
another victim and Andy I was very
surprised to see him again Epstein and
Maxwell were making lewd jokes about
Randy Andy I had the impression that
Andy had come there to see Epstein and
to have sex with me there was no other
apparent purpose for Andy to be there I
was told to go upstairs of Andy and to
go to the room I fought off as the
dungeon the massage room but it was
really scary-looking
I had sex with an Leader I was only paid
$400 from Epstein for servicing Andy
that time the third time I had sex if
Andy was in an orgy on Epstein's private
island in the US Virgin Islands I was
around 18 Epstein Andy approximately
eight other young girls and I had sex
together so even though she was 18 and
it's not an offense
she is witnessing other minor children
in this orgy with Prince Andrew the
other girls all seemed and appeared to
be under the age of 18 and didn't really
speak English
the major co-conspirators as well as
Madame Maxwell is a guy called Jean Luc
Bernal who run the modeling agency out
of France and he was procuring East
European girls Russian girls people from
poor families he sent Epstein triplets
twelve-year-old triplets as a birthday
gift who performed oral sex on Epstein
and Epstein was bragging about it for
weeks I'm a bit speechless at that yeah
they up my other sort of question is do
we know so well she basically sent home
by these people so it would be come
perform the act and then go home or was
it she would be living in the mansion
with him and sort of or do you not know
that she was a runaway at first but an
overstatement she talks about her dad
being with her and then I going in
somewhere so I think that her
relationship with her family was tenuous
because a lot of the people that they
targeted didn't have that their lawn
maybe structure make no mistake yeah if
you end up being controlled in this sort
of way like we looked at the air the r
kelly documentary it's it's very rarely
from people who come from
in caring families who who will allow
this to go I know who will who will let
you just not call home for months on end
in a fight it's people who are easy
targets I'm not being funny but I feel
like our Kelly at this point is
beginning you feel like a distraction
from everything else do you know I'm not
saying he didn't do terrible things but
I know he's like look what he did he's
terrible we're the good guys for
exposing these well Kelly the difference
between these guys and our Kelly is our
Kelly didn't have the infrastructure to
keep going he didn't have the money that
we're talking about a different level
over here we're not about an entertainer
who got rich we're talking about wealthy
if you want to know the level just read
some of the names let's just cover this
very very quickly so yeah what sent this
didn't you
so the reason that a lot of people
started coming on my channel for Epstein
stuff was a week before Epstein died I
put a video up and a lot of people have
said that he was gonna die I'm not
claiming that's brilliant or anything
important
I did actually described that he would
get killed in prison and it will be made
to look like a suicide and Bill Clinton
will probably be behind it that's what I
pause besides prediction score that's
pretty close to the nozzle I mean it's
either that or we need so so I really
wish I put a bell nah people start to
come up a chance to became like the
girls to Channel four Epstein News and
someone out the blue just kindly sent me
the unredacted black book before it had
widely circulated online so as you can
see there it is it's got all these names
I've circled some of the more
interesting ones for you okay so there's
there's this long list of negatives yeah
if you just go through a couple of those
what I want to do is put context on the
names where we read that okay so it's
important to put context on what the
book is so what is his little black book
okay so this is the book of contacts
that was taken by the police and is in
the court system as legal discovery for
these cases so what does the little
black book mean does the little black
book mean you are part of it the little
black book does not mean you are an
international child sex trafficking
pedophile yeah
but it increases the likelihood that you
are connected with people who are doing
their and by looking at a severe
bad guy yeah if he's got you in his book
like all right there's a chance you're
not involved but it isn't a good look is
it no know what I mean and if you look
at how many phone numbers if you look at
the names and see like they've got one
or two numbers you know they're probably
okay okay so just in the context you're
saying the more phone numbers that the
likelihood why do you need to know every
phone number he's got so this is a bit
strange so for example Liz Hurley big
celebrity he's only got one phone number
for her Donald Trump however he's got
about 15 phone numbers for Donald Trump
so he has some reason he really needed
to know how to get in contact with
Donald Trump so why I'm not saying that
Donald Trump is one of these people but
it's not a good look there's no sauce
then why so many phone numbers are these
would how why have so many factor would
Epstein go down the list until he gets
an answer or what what's the deal of
having 15 phone numbers all I can
speculate is that the closer he was to
someone the more numbers he would need
yeah so can I go from a few of these
please cuz I like to feel like I'm in
the North I'd love to I mean if you
really want to be in the know head over
to Sean's channel what we're doing right
now so yeah should we call some of them
so we've got happy for example David
Rockefeller he's got a good five numbers
for him relief jagger only one or two so
maybe nothing was calming Jagger and his
disconnect with that one although Mick
Jagger merely maybe just needed one
number I don't know
well okay it's getting Kissinger Henry
Kissinger who was described in the last
podcast we did with David Icke for being
a real piece of [__] yeah is everywhere
any conspiracies you find he is every
he's an every conspiracy this guy he
napalm the lot Kennedy family are all
over here as well really the Kennedy
family had been a sort of cursed family
they've had so much bad luck in their
history haven't they yeah Courtney Love
got about four numbers photo-quality
love just came out last week and said
Prince Andrew showed up at her house
while in sex is as if Courtney Love sort
of likes mixing it with these sorts of
weird people caught it I mean did you
have a I mean we're going off topic yeah
but did you hear about the conspiracy
that she was behind the murder
I've watched the document on it of
Nathan Kurt Cobain because it was the
investigator she hired that made that
documentary because he grew so
suspicious I I genuinely after watching
that was i Yakko copy was probably
murdered yeah Bradley cuz he was
actually a really beautiful artist yeah
who stood to gain the most from it all
those right yeah so yeah there's a lot
of like lot of basically wealthy people
in here powerful people in here it's
amazing how many who is there anyone in
there I mean and Brian's looking through
the map is there anyone in there that
particularly surprised yours anyway what
big names are we looking for got like
Tony blur yeah few politicians names
that surprised you sure not yeah so he'd
be in there like Naomi Campbell right
okay there's a few hum bit disappointed
in Chris Tucker is there a lot number
Chris Tucker one two three four five six
that's what Chris Tucker see I really
and I've got to be honest I really do
you like Rochelle yeah I love I'll be
honest as well I really enjoyed Chris
Tucker stand that's all for right now
drop your charm yeah but there any
there's no jay-z and beyonce so no
definitely not Kanye yeah honey is it
thick women yes
Kanye if anything yeah massage in like
just like just so many [__] numbers
there with it I love I love some of the
little what I'm realizing in these what
he's putting things for himself to
remember later like so like yeah massage
in Paris he's got I'd say about 20
numbers here so it's like Debbie Mary
and then in brackets next to one of them
he's for Stefan in bracket better than
gypsy
so like just so he knows like each one
was grading them again that probably
means like
right David Copperfield
the magician yeah he could make things
disappear Wow alright so we got we get
the point there's a there's a [__] ton
of very famous people in there in like
you're talking Trump's you're talking
the biggest of the biggest people rock
Dola family torn anything about golden
shower next to trump just checking um
you know a thanks for bringing these and
you did ring some of them did you get
any answers our nominees I just got some
like voicemails that's all messages are
saying get subscribed during your heads
up you're on the Epstein's black book
would love to you like it is no it's not
men why you're in it
these people have known mostly if they
were in the book probably well when I
went to ghilane Maxwell's London
property one of the names in the
blackboard was the pub off was it the
street or reenacts head huh so had the
names of the owners him and his wife and
the phone numbers so I went into the pop
bought some drinks and said by the way
do you know you're in Jeffery Epstein's
black book and they got that gun out and
you left well he did he did get quite
irate What did he say what did he say he
said you're only buying [__] water
why you're only buying water you're
coming in my pub that's why you look so
[__] old you because you don't drink
oh yeah it was a nasty piece I'm sorry
understood
usually the opposite you might you know
mate this man is he's a recovering
alcoholic 92 yeah you know I actually
think me hilarious you took Brian some
of these things just because I don't
think you get the same trouble well I
would actually be interested in doing a
bit of like you know when Louis Theroux
just rocks up so yeah and he's just like
doesn't give a [__]
puts himself on the line so I want to I
want to say a daunting Liz Hurley was
involved in any of the scenes I think
this is you wanting Liz well I don't I
mean god bless her she's she is a
timeless classic isn't she he's also got
weirdly UPS delivery so you you rung a
lot of these you didn't you didn't get
anything in particular out of it but it
just alludes to the fact of who might
have been involved isn't it okay so
there's two grand conspiracies here
but is the child sex trafficking
conspiracy who was responsible for that
criminal operation then there's also the
conspiracy in the murder of Jeffrey
Epstein and some of those people from
the first conspiracy my lead suspects in
the second that's naturally because it's
it's the people who've got the most to
lose if it goes to court and it all
unravels because as we're saying in
other big cases when when when you've
got a gun to your head in your face and
life in prison you sing like a [__]
canary and I would imagine that's the
way it would have went because why take
the fall for all of these people so
Jeffrey Epstein and his first sweetheart
deal like I said he got the prostitution
with the underage girls and he was
basically on work release for this year
now on his second arrest how that came
about was a journalist very brave woman
out of America she was interviewing
female prisoners I think they were in
the Florida prison system and she found
a commonality among a lot of them was
they had been doing stuff for Epstein
hmm what'd he say doing stuff um sexual
sex reps team yeah massages that was his
code name for the sex acts a lot of them
come from foster homes care homes abused
so when we see massages in that
phonebook so I just means sex right okay
so because I literally just thought
you'd like some massage I didn't really
get that it's also kind of weird because
you think you've got everything else in
that book why put my son why make that
the code yeah you know okay I was gonna
wait Epstein himself calling to the
victims like to have free massages a day
we've on the Ridge girls he had to
ejaculate at least thrice three times a
day and when one of the victims asked
him why he needed to do that three times
a day said it was to him it was just
like eating food right well he just
needed it so we're talking you know I
knew people described these like
predators as like just like hungry eat
like animals almost like we're talking
about someone who is just an animal like
at that point he's not thinking he's
just [__] yeah you want they do
almost it's not really a everyday
mentality is it these people are sort of
turned over time to become this kind of
character psychopathic child predators
so it's it's unique yet there's not many
I don't believe there's many at that
level of wealth you know Bill Clinton's
got that with he was on the Lolita
Express what was it 26 times short took
come you explain what that means the
Lolita
okay so Epstein had the pedophile island
aha which I mentioned earlier and he
also had the Lolita Express which was a
plane with a bed so it was out of any
legal jurisdiction it's flying around
he's got the victims trapped in this you
know in the into the sky basically on
this plane and the girls were servicing
the customers on the lolis Express now
you know Bill Clinton was on okay one of
the things that gave me a head up on who
the conspirators are the main suspects
in the murder are the people who
protested the most about their innocence
and right away Bill Clinton came out and
disavowed Epstein he then said he'd only
been on his planes four times but
cording to the flight manifest okay so
this is the log that was on it almost
thirty times that we know of at least if
you're gonna have a pedophile plane why
keep a log manifest why is that sort of
the Lord although if so maybe a shuttle
log every person gets on that plane
which makes it sort of a stupid plan in
the first place well it's also very
stupid of Clinton to say only four times
when he's going to be rumbled for it has
it has it come out that he's been other
just you and a few others no it's
generally accepted that Clinton has lied
that Clinton was on this Lolita Express
almost thirty times and that Clinton is
deep in the mix and that Epstein it
follows the trajectory of Arkansas and
people wonder why Hillary found it's so
easy to forgive Clinton for [__]
Monica Lewinsky and it's like that was
literally the tip of the iceberg and now
he was well aware of it
that Monica Lewinsky thing was a
publicity smokescreen for all the other
stuff that was going on in Clinton's
life at that point in time he had
multiple rape suits filed against him
that he settled out of court all right
so when you saw Hillary doing speeches
and people showing up with Billy's a
rapist t-shirts during the election
that's what that was all about and Trump
actually brought to one of the events he
brought bills rape victims that he's
settled with they were all next women in
a row and at one of the events so why
Trump doesn't give a [__] to be fair
like doesn't Trump was already said that
he knew Epstein was a womanizer but the
difference between him and and Epstein
was the Epstein like on the rich girls
young girls so eyes Epstein got Trump's
number so much in this book well they're
all in the mix the government these are
just different mafias right but so Trump
isn't exactly blameless in this or he's
not we just have any proof of ways all
these are different mafias that are at
war with each other you got the Bosch
and Clinton crime families working
together you got the Trump mafia working
against the Clintons they're seen he's
working with the Russian it's just what
was funny it literally is just like
gangsters isn't it but it at such a
level whether they're untouchable Iran
such a bomb you have to raise a finger
they could kill anyone anywhere in the
world so they wrote but at the same time
doesn't feel as glamorous is the real
mafia that is nice well I did all of the
accents or the music well not only that
there are meatballs they're also doing
it so the Mafia for me always feels a
little bit like they're trying to
maintain a community there's something
about it you know what I mean it's like
self policing in Italy in some ways I
don't know Matthew did terrible things
these people are just doing all for
self-interest also Italian mafia you
don't harm women or kids yeah but these
deviants you know just trafficking girls
from Eastern Europe there are kids and
then having orgies with them and having
them have sex of each other with
strap-ons that's a different level isn't
it yeah are you concerned that you might
not have your facts right in regards to
pointing the finger at the Clintons of
you have you naturally investing in this
before you go out on a video and say
these things you got I think I better
[__] have this right because you
haven't got a you've got a lot of
evidence but you haven't got the pick
each other that's the thing that proves
that Clinton did it you've got 27 times
on a plane that was used in a lot of sex
crimes but you haven't got the final
piece of the puzzle here are you
concerned that you might have it wrong
and you never will with the Clintons
because it all gets swept under the
carpet all of my research is based on
the Arkansas State Police who were
Bill Clinton the ones who are still
alive that is and the victims statements
about what actually happened with them
and these elite pedophiles so the
trajectory of the arc aside murders I
believe goes all the way to Epstein I'm
not saying that Bill Clinton solely was
the grand conspirator but I think he is
definitely at the top of that pyramid so
let me have written extensively about
Pablo Escobar so let's say the Cali
cartel and the Medellin Cartel are not
at war they're at peace so I'll say
someone in Cali as pissed-off Pablo
Escobar and that person's got to go so
Pablo Escobar would get on the phone -
Gilberto the head of the Cali cartel I
say this this this person's got a goal
now let's look at this in the context of
Epstein so you've got the legal eruption
was in America the liability was there
who's just come out of government in
America Hillary Clinton
they've got massive power base in in
politics in America who's the other
person who's got the most to lose about
this if people are focusing on Prince
Andrew the Royal Mafia so you get the
Royal you know Prince Andrew puts a call
in to Clinton or whoever / they've got a
common vicious on your turn yeah you got
to clean this up basically there that's
how I think it went down something like
that hmm in regards to Clinton you've
got a bit of proof in that he silenced
people have you looked into the
testimonies from those victims or are
there completely silenced how have this
because you know how they have to sign
in an NDA or whatever have any of them
spoken out after that or not well some
have done stuff I'm over the years and
they did stuff with Trump so I'm not
exactly sure under the terms of their
non-disclosure agreements how they were
able to do all that but some have spoken
out when anyone could Google online Bill
Clinton sexual assault suits
non-disclosure agreements and you'll see
all that stuff on disclosure agreement
if you're just sitting there as part of
a rant what what most people say is a
random group you've not disclose you've
not legally disclosed anything you could
be sitting there yeah like in The
Godfather when they brought in Darrell
yes about to testify exactly this
happens to be there you know and Bill
Clinton obviously knows who that is yeah
yeah so can we go into the circumstances
around Epstein's death yeah so you
described how the second time the
journalists found out he'd been going
with these women in the prison what
happened from that then how did he get
because he was on day release it seemed
like he was out and leave the prison
during the day okay so when one of these
elite pedophile power players is
uncovered at that level they'll
sacrifice the lower level in a heartbeat
but at the higher level of epstein the
pedophile circle will protect that
person as far as possible so in the
first case the sweetheart deal Acosta
was the prosecutor who handled that for
the pedophile circle he was given up
steam was given this pass and I cost her
you know it's like all this criticism
for that and he was part of you know
Trump's government now as well so this
all you know like I said the incestuous
thing once the media frenzy gets so big
that this powerful circle can no longer
protect even a high-level player then
that player gets sacrificed so with
Jimmy Savile they protected him and he
died to the end to the end yeah maybe
sickening to the end with Epstein
they've tried to protect them on the
second round he had to go so with Savile
because he was really really old when it
all came out about him after he died
there was no need to worry because there
was not know he wasn't going to uncover
and he wasn't gonna give any testimony
so it was like it all died with him
whereas they didn't have that luxury
with absolutely it's the criminal case
once it gets into the court system and
things are documented legally certain
government agencies have to act on that
information so that's why Epstein was
killed because to stop that from arising
and that's why
Helene Maxwell and Jean Luc Bernal will
be next so so before we got in here the
second the second
case happens after that brave journalist
who you mentioned uncovers more of his
issues yeah
is that what led him to go into this
prison cell where eventually killed
himself of allegedly killed himself but
couldn't protect him anymore
mm-hmm he's now saying that he's gonna
start giving up names he says I'm gonna
give up five names because he wants to
cut a deal to try and get his sentence
reduced
he's getting legal visits all day long
there's no way he thinks he's gonna lose
this case again he's thinking I'm gonna
play the system he's caught this thing
called a double jeopardy motion filed in
the court system and what that means is
you cannot be convicted twice of the
same crimes and here we go again round
two for the same crimes so he thinks
he's gonna play the system again and get
out of it he's even telling his lawyers
you know this is gonna work out even
right up until the end he's got all
these legal visits all day long he's in
good spirits but if he goes to three
weeks prior to his death that's when
things the weird things that had to
happen so we got the two grand
conspiracies that are described and
we've named some of the major players
there's probably a lot more people out
there there are co-conspirators but now
I've also got to look at the methods of
the murder and the instrument of the
murder and how that was played out
because I do have a suspect of the
instrument whoever did it or has
knowledge of watch them to my knowledge
there was a suicide attempt before the
final day he died is that right when he
was in three weeks prior to his death he
was found unconscious in his jail cell
with injuries to his neck now in prison
there's a rule when you go in I think we
talked about this in off of Wall Street
one where the gang members come up to
you right away and it's a charge check
what are your charges so if you've got a
sex offense
it's Kos kill on sight and these gang
members will do that right away if you
know you're going to get attacked at the
very least so they put into Epstein's
cell
this massive guy Nicolas Tartaglia Oni
who's murdered four dudes in a drug deal
gone bad
he lured them to his brother's nightclub
I think four dudes and I think they were
buried in his garden or something like
that
this guy was also an ex-cop so he's got
ties to law enforcement as well now the
natural order of things in prison is
such that if you've murdered four people
and someone gets put in your cell but is
a sex offender I don't know any case
where that guy would not attempt to
murder that person even without getting
paid off to do it but I also believe
that the pot there's a possibility that
this guy's facing the death penalty
someone could have said hey you know do
us a favor here and we'll only give you
life in prison I will give you 25 and
you'll be up for parole after 25 that
could have been some kind of quid pro
quo like that because if you look at
photos of this guy Nicolas star they
just are they openly available online
yeah Nicolas Google Images boom put
Epstein Selmy Nicolas Taglioni and yeah
you should flash it for of that up on
the video just so people can re-edit I
will be right now if ever there was a
big guy he's got dogs so it's quite
sweet really yeah yeah me he's a [__]
giant he's a killing machine
squeezing someone's head off their
[__] shoulders for him wouldn't be
too much trouble he could rip Epstein's
head straight up no problem yeah yeah ok
so let's go back to the people he looks
like your worst nightmare as a soul mate
yeah let's go that size in prison
I guess their ID smuggled in no [__] so
Epstein is found unconscious in the cell
three weeks prior to his death Epstein
said to his lawyers that he was attacked
by this guy and after the incident he
was placed on suicide watch six days
later on July 29
taking off suicide watch and placed in a
special housing unit with another inmate
Epstein's close associate said he was in
good spirits now if you're gonna take
someone out in prison you got to make it
look like a normal method but prisoners
used to kill themselves and there's all
kinds of different methods prisoners
used to kill themselves so you go
hanging you know people can just get
bedsheets
try and hang from the ceiling or the
windows or they could just leave without
even thrown weight and I'll flush the
sheet down the toilet and lean it I had
ex prison guard on my true crime podcast
Neilson when he was talking about he
found a corpse that was just leaning
like that forward that's how he'd hung
himself
hotshot which is an overdose of heroin
90% of prisoners injecting drugs where I
was housed gang member doesn't like you
sticks a needle in you of those heroin
guards find that that's just another
dead junkie as far as they're concerned
jumping you got people jumping off
balconies sometimes in sheriff to our
pious jail they wouldn't even die they
just break their legs break their spines
and they'd still be alive and in the
jail you got suicide by god I once saw
this guy just run past my cell he had
like a neckerchief over his face we were
like a 1 foot long shank he's out the
fence just yelling at the guard yelling
at the guards they bring out a SWAT team
with live rounds and they're all just
facing him and they're gonna just mow
him down but he back down at the last
minute so they didn't kill him but yeah
if you wanted to just run at them yeah
they wipe you out exactly right pretty
quick that way yeah then you got a
hunger strike and you got people doing
crazy stuff like drinking bleach eating
razor blades okay so of all of those
methods if you're gonna whack someone in
a jail
I reckon hanging in hotshot are going to
be the two easiest to facilitate to get
away with it
and honeying seems like the one that
would be the most believable that he did
it in there for right there's nothing to
say here let's all move on with you easy
is it just choke someone
sleep well yeah I mean if you watch any
UFC fight he'll know how to do that
pretty quickly so this guy could have
been choked out and then just yeah we'll
just pop the the bed sheet around his
neck afterwards and there you can think
of some cracker yeah
but not only that the video footage from
around that time in the prison or got
the cameras all malfunctioned
it's 911 all over if you work with
cameras all time all the time how often
does the comrade face its Rovin working
with them like don't malfunction often
up another bad word said about them yeah
okay so that makes it massively
suspicious and the guards on duty all
fell asleep no way to be fair what's a
Sunday night so do you know where do you
know how CCTV in a prism work yes
so does it go to one central place what
does it do like do you necessarily know
that or is it good to go to an office in
the prison or to go to somewhere else
where it's then okay so I recorded yeah
and sheriff joe arpaio jail were guards
were murdering mentally ill prisoners
and i've got videos of them doing it on
my youtube channel i obtained that
footage
so just be clear you know Sean earlier
when you said I don't know I'm getting
do you monetize not dr1 go them in the
world of that is a really clear Shan
you're a smart guy how did you obtain
that for example okay all of the cameras
are viewing all of the major areas like
the day rooms and the hallways and you
know what the prisoners going into the
cells and stuff like that and they some
of the cameras could see into the cells
as well so all that footage is stored by
the agency running the prison so that
was Arizona State in my case in this
case you know it's the feds that would
have had that video material now that
video material becomes obtainable when
there are lawsuits and people suing
court and it forces the prison to
release the footage right so in the case
of the clip I got family members
of the victims of the guards suit the
jail and the jail was forced to release
that video footage through the federal
court system Brian so that's how this
footage comes out through the courts but
if the cameras with malfunctioned you
file suit all day long it's never going
to come out if the guards had fallen
asleep and if Nicholas Tartaglia knee
has got earbuds in that night so he
conveniently can't hear anything I think
you think men we need the other words
yeah to be fair of my respect night yeah
I mean that must be terrible so Nicholas
was not Epstein Selma at this point in
time so a lot of people are saying so
obviously Nicholas didn't kill Epstein
because he was been moved to a different
cell this was after the attack had
happened so they said after the first
attack all right so they moved him or
enough in a in a neighboring cell though
now it is not difficult for prisoners to
open the cell door and go into other
prisoners cells doesn't happen or
they're not locked off though yeah
they've got all kinds of different ways
of getting in people's doors okay
they Jimmy the locks and they put things
in the locks and before people get
locked down they put things in their
locks okay so and if the prison guards
are like yeah let's just let this happen
then it's a very very easy then yeah so
are Taglioni I believe is at the top of
the murder suspect listen and even if he
didn't do it with bare hands he has
information he knew what went on in that
area on that night and he knows a lot a
lot more that could possibly come out
with you know where he is now
yeah he's getting released on Monday
he's getting punished right now let me
just say one other thing the injuries
that have been released to Epstein's
neck he had a hyoid fracture and a hyoid
fracture is more common with someone
getting strangled to death than it is
with suicide and right you can't real
suicide out boy it's way more common
with homicide there's a different kind
of trauma created when you're strangled
then when it's you're allowing it to
happen isn't it because there's a
struggle isn't it a little different
thing going on that's why this is such a
brilliant way to kill someone and make
it look like yeah
a death by strangulation because um does
that overlap between the two
so the marks were more consistent with
being choked than hanging himself one
expert said Tartaglia Oni was worrying
is this expert so it in Rome is this
expert someone who's actually seen the
body these are all medical experts that
have given their opinions online various
Soutar Taglioni was wearing earbuds when
investigators went to question him about
the incidence Epstein was found dead in
the cell at Metropolitan Correctional
Center in New York City at 6:30 a.m. on
August 10th 2019 and the jail I'm sorry
the conventional news story was but he
committed suicide because the conditions
were so bad in the Metropolitan
Correctional Center nobody heard
anything said Tartaglia on his lawyer he
was listen to his Rihanna album it was a
silent act this act Leone's lawyer Nick
knows a hell of a lot about what went on
he was there during the first attempt
and he was there when he actually killed
himself it just wasn't in the same cell
so FBI and Justice Department inspector
general have launched investigators into
Epstein's death and like I said earlier
you've got the dad of the headmaster the
Gators
so our Tagliani has not been contacted
by investigators he's facing the death
penalty and wherever I'll not he'll be
in a position to cooperate remains
unclear his lawyer said be next I warn
you they'll bump him off next cause he
what they'd have done is a little great
something with him and then they'll get
rid of him well he'll be like with
Kennedy it was Oswald and then Jack Ruby
he went off didn't he it's Article II
only certainly has information that
would be very valuable to the
investigation if they want access to it
so tart ugly only they're saying that
he's been kicking off about the
condition so they've been punishing him
for that and the
right big men get uncomfortable easier I
empathize with them yeah so you you then
said that there was two other people who
you felt were co-conspirators who would
be who would be next in line to
magically disappear somehow so okay so
we got ghilane maxwell and i've already
described it something so that was the
pimp the madame man okay yeah and when
you went and knocked on the door sorry
who was that sorry a relative no that
was a clean all right yeah so what she
decide yeah I've got no idea what you're
on about me yeah just cleared that clean
outside but you know that's probably
seeing some [__] though you know I bet I
bet that clean owed me for an
interesting interview yeah she would but
this stuff is you're not interested what
she's like no I said can I come in the
house and film girls no like on the
basis of you know I'm there's probably
there's probably people who might may
have died in that building or this or
there's a lot of dark [__] going on in
the actual family history yeah and the
fact that you're knocking on that door
and trying to expose this you're doing
good work really so well done man thanks
yeah all right so I've got ghilane
pegged as conspirator B Road Epstein is
a Chrismukkah lanes B so in my case
there was over 100 people Co defendants
arrested here and the prosecutors they
give everybody a letter of the alphabet
so I was a wild woman was B he well mom
was C and so on and so on downtown
obviously naturally the you know the
first letter is gonna be the most
powerful person then yeah so ghilane
I've come to this conclusion because of
multiple witness victim statements and
I'll just read some of the other girl
who was present during this stuff of
Prince Andrew this is what she said this
is Joanna's
statement they lured her from school to
have sex with Epstein under the guise of
hiring her for a job answering phones as
with Virginia
Madame Maxwell approached joanna while
trolling Joanna's school grounds she
lured Joanna into her and Epstein's home
offering them this job at the pretext
only lasted a day so she was a young
college student nearly 2,000 miles from
home she was instructed to massage
Epstein and it was made clear that her
purpose was to bring Epstein to orgasm
during these massages so that ghilane
did not have to what and when did you
first meet Maxwell this is what she
answers 2001 March probably end of
February beginning of March and how did
you meet her she approached me while I
was on campus at Palm Beach Atlantic
College and how long did you work in
that position answering phones just that
one day and what happened the second
time you came to the house at that point
I met Amy Taylor and she took me to
Jeffrey's bathroom and he was present
her and I both massaged Jeffrey she was
showing me how to massage and then he
got off the table she took she got on
the table she took off her clothes got
on the table and then he was showing me
moves that he liked and then I took my
clothes off they asked me to get on the
table so I could feel it they both
massaged me who did any work for ghilane
Maxwell did Maxwell ever refer to a me
by any particular name she called her
her sex slave did Jeffrey ever tell you
why he received so many massages from so
many different girls he explained he
needed to have three orgasms a day it
was biological like eating was that
anything he was supposed to do in order
to get the camera I did not know that
there were expectations of me to get the
camera until after Maxwell had purchased
the camera for me and I was over there
giving Jeffrey a massage I did not know
that Maxwell was in possession of the
camera until later she told me call me
after I had left and said I have the
camera for you but you cannot receive it
yet because you came here and didn't
finish your job and I had to finish it
for you and did you what did you
understand her to mean she was implying
that I did not get
free off and so she had to do it do you
mean bringing him to orgasm yes based on
what you knew did Maxwell know that the
type of massages Jeffrey was getting
involved sex acts yes what was Maxwell's
main job with respect to Jeffrey beyond
companionship her job as it related to
me was to find other girls that would
perform massages for him and herself
then she testified about the acts that
occurred with her and Prince Andrew this
is a separate testimony now about Andrew
when they were at Epstein's Manhattan
mansion tell me how it came to be that
there was a picture taken I remember
someone suggesting a photo and they told
us to get on the couch and so Prince
Andrew and Virginia that's the other
victim sat on the couch and they put a
puppet a puppet on her lap and so then I
sat on Andrews lap and I believe on my
own volition they took the puppets hands
and put it on Virginia's breasts
and so Andrew put his on mine and her
testimony corroborates Virginia's
testimony how they were recruited under
a ruse of legitimate jobs to bring them
into the household to have sex with
Epstein and it corroborates how
Virginia's account have been lent out to
Prince Andrew and also how Prince Andrew
used the puppet to touch Virginia's
breasts while using to touch while using
number hands a touch Joanna's breast
right okay yeah so I Prince Andrew
answered a single question about this
when this was blowing up two weeks or so
two or three weeks ago Andrew I think he
was in New York in some big property
down there with Fergie so they were at
the Royal Palace not the right path and
Balmoral is it with the Queen but then
the old boy showed up what's his name
Prince Philip who doesn't get along with
Fergie so they had to skedaddle and they
went off and hid now I know someone have
some contacts close to this and they
said that they were at Farnborough
Airport Fergie in Andrew completely
surrounded by Secret Service people and
bodyguards and they wouldn't talk to
anyone and they just completely left the
country
hurry hoping that this would blow over
and then they pull out some little petit
Royale stories about other things to try
and get the heat off them when they came
back you saw some other stuff making
headlines I just obviously brought this
one before and this was on the 19th of
August they used a picture there's a lot
of pictures Prince Andrew seems to have
being friends with Donald Trump for
decades by the way I can see on Google
you
Prince Andrew says he's appalled by
Jeffrey Epstein alleged crimes what it
what a ridiculous thing to say at this
point
like you we all know it now man come on
so many of these will be appalled no but
so many of these victims are coming out
and being like yeah he was they they
happened with him like they're all
saying it well the ones who designed the
most I've got the most guilt as far as
I'm concerned that was Prince Andrew
Bill Clinton and Alan Dershowitz the
lawyer Alan Derry was involved Hillary
okay so Bill Clinton is the sexual
assault cocaine head rapist philanderer
and Hillary Clinton is the balls of the
operation and the brains from my
research that's what I've been led to
believe his early victims with the
sexual assault suits that was settled
Hillary Clinton had people private
investigators finding now all of these
early assault victims not because she
was jealous of Bill she was gonna tell
them a mouth but to have people go and
threaten their lives so that his
ascendancy to the presidency would not
be impacted so she has got a complete
heart of ice so what you're says that
the last election was really a battle
like a Mafia battle between the two a
complete mafia battle and at the top
level of international Mathew right now
Donald Trump Donald the Don has got
Prince Andrew by the balls because let's
say the Queen of England had been in one
of these sexual orgies with the underage
girls
she would have diplomatic immunity
because of her status but Prince Andrew
doesn't have the same level of
diplomatic immunity but I was wondering
there his diplomatic immunity rests in a
decision by the president just so
happens a he's made for 20-odd [__]
years yeah so Donald Trump actually
could come out quite well in town
power plays because now there's now
they're gonna love all Donald now
they're gonna be like thanks for looking
after us a lot of people say it's not
coincidence yeah a lot of people saying
it's not a coincidence that the
sweetheart deal the Epstein got happened
under the obama-clinton regime and that
it's come the second round has come out
on the Trump perhaps of some kind of
power play dynamic because that because
he's very good friends with Trump
clearly from all these [__] pictures
they've got together and he's goes way
back with Clinton Nord oh yes I love
house cuz lots of love so far oh no no
bomb anyone but Obama well actually the
thing is I really enjoyed the bombers
but obviously at the time that we all
want to like him nor don't we everyone
wants to like him but like for instance
today with Clinton now I'm like yeah you
know in the past I've heard lovely
things about what Bill Clinton's
presidency is done for certain people
and obviously that didn't stop that I
hate him now so let's try it can I hate
Obama now as well oh do we have to
Obama's not been sloppy if he's got any
dirty laundry
he is squeaky clean it's been cleaned
vici so what you're saying is there's a
you go get to that status though unless
you've done something or unless you've
been involved in some way from my
research in the book America made and we
are being lied to about the war on drugs
I believe that Clinton was able to
become the president of America because
he played ball with the CIA and George
HW Bush by providing all this security
to the cocaine importation operation
Larry Nichols who worked for the Clinton
said there was a hundred million dollars
worth a month of cocaine money getting
laundered in this operation of a lot of
that when to help Clinton become the
president wherever it was a you know
paying for people to go out and campaign
for him a lot of it went into his
election campaigning yeah they were
scratching each other's back so then the
baton was passed on for the presidency
even though they're on opposite sides of
like left and right and then he passes
it back to George Bush jr. that's like
what I said to us last week a host
podcast they say it doesn't really
matter what side you're on either way
they're at the top so just the glint on
Prince Andrew am i right is he the
brother of Prince Charles is that right
Yeah right Charles we'll get it next
well so wait it's Prince Charles soon
top effects were just really ugly women
but anyway and then Diana imagine him
going god I've got a shag Diana and he's
like I fancy the other yeah it's not
really my type beautiful women she's
she's she's gorgeous
Prince house I know I don't want to
think that the royal family this is the
worst scandal probably since the death
of Diana to hit the royal family yeah
they cannot be seen to just go yeah we
had nothing to do with that sure the
amount of people who are just googled it
on news and like nine hours ago there
was a woman coming out saying yeah he
abused me and in the bath what you said
in the bathroom is there what the [__]
happens now like they have to answer to
this so when the first round of
allegations came out from the victims
and Andrew is vehemently denying this
and categorically untrue and all this
stuff
well video starts get leaked out didn't
they yeah of Andrew peeping out of
Epstein's New York property leaving it's
like these girls and Epstein on the
street with another girl so you can see
that he's deeply in the mix all the
arrests are the arresting on the fact
that Donald Trump is going to have to
just sort of let this all blow over and
not take action Donald Trump could use
this as a power play and be like look
I've got all these guys by the balls
right now
I could I could let this go to the next
court level but I could stop it and say
to these people look you know you owe me
one I can expand my empire to Scotland
or whatever he's gonna do yeah this is
matters and so you same with you for
another term every election confirmed
yeah I think that you will win because
have also not got a viable alternative
have a Tim's if the irony is that the
main guy right now who is opposite
Donald Trump is any Sanders Bernie
Sanders but also the guy who was the
vice president the war bamos oh we're
sorry yeah slicked back gray hair
Joe Biden yeah Joe Biden look and
ironically look at all the footage of
Joe Biden touching up all those [__]
kids as well like this thing where I
came on and said you
there's a satanic sort of pedo element
to the elite and the power mod people
who are trying to run for office like
there's bound to be some good guys out
there there's bound to be some people up
there who just want to make a difference
but I mean [__] me when you watch Joe
Biden you watch the way George senior
was around you've seen the videos of him
touching people inappropriately as well
John George Bush Senior was Oh grab
analysis now he's a bit but yeah it's
not just that as well it's just a creepy
element that was his illness there
wasn't it Brian beyond this excuse I
don't think you get to the presidential
level unless you're gonna play ball with
these guys yeah they've got the goods on
you for something deviant that you've
done like with Clinton all the stuff but
when I first started coming up with this
stuff going basically you are videoed or
photographed doing inappropriate things
with a minor or whatever and then
they've got you forever and then they
can basically control the decisions you
make when I first heard that was I I
mean it sounds like you know a novel you
know I mean it sounds interesting but
surely not and now like I'm just like
yeah probably well the victim just
saying that Epstein's trying to get
information and the goods on these
people so we can have a hold on them and
I think it's Joey I'm gonna point it out
that Alex Jones years ago was saying
that there was a pedophile Island
yeah we're celebs and politicians were
going and all this stuff was gay and
everyone just laughter AJ back then
saying this this is the island yeah and
Alex to him said a lot but on the year
that was bang on about like 9/11 and it
sort of predicted what was gonna happen
who they were going to play him okay you
you've you've probably watched a lot of
Alex Jones he's been deep platformed I'm
just interested to know what you what
you think about him so I've watched his
interviews with people like Freeway
Ricky rush mmm he and Freeway Ricky Ross
is that's not the rick ross the rap iris
this is the real rick ross whom rick
ross stole his name from just read my
book we are being lied to
is about four different characters i
talked about the boys on the tracks so
their mom Linda Ives mom of one of the
boys that's how I start that book out
next chapter it goes over to the life
story of Freeway Ricky Ross
so Freeway Ricky Ross
born in Texas is mom dirt-poor
dad left them it's just him and his
brother live with his mom they move over
to California and he's in school some of
his mates that's saying yeah you know
we're making all this money selling this
stuff cocaine to these white you know
jock like college kids and that arouses
his interest because he's seen movies
like Superfly that have glamorized the
drugs lifestyle so he starts this
cocaine business and ends up becoming
the biggest cocaine crack overlord on
the west coast of America but what he
didn't know was I talked about the pilot
Barry seal earlier the cocaine coming in
that was the CIA sponsored by the CIA
his supplier Danny Loeb Landon was part
of that operation he was bringing it in
for the CIA money going down to fight
this war with the Contras in Nicaragua
so years later when Rick Ross is in
prison a journalist called Gary Webb now
this is the third person my book is
about is Gary Webb the fourth person is
Kiki Camarena which narcos was about the
Mexican knockoff season so Gary Webb the
journalist Rick Ross has got this life
sentence and he's in prison and Gary
Webb the journalist he's uncovered now
that the cocaine was coming from this
CIA operation that Rick rush still
didn't know about he shows up at prison
and tells rick ross hey here's what went
down rick ross is pretty much illiterate
he's teaching himself how to read so he
can file motions and get legal playing
the system so he can eventually get out
and he'd been sent some of the three
strike laws but some of those strikes
had come under the same case so he makes
it he strikes down and to get released
then he starts doing interviews with
people who actually visit him in prison
like Montel Williams Montel Williams
that is show on this massively famous TV
presenter back then in America yeah Alex
Jones went to visit Rick Ross in prison
as well so that's how Alex Jones
established his relationship with Rick
Ross and it's just on another interview
with Rick Ross in the past couple of
weeks talking about you know how Rick
Ross's life has turned out on what Rick
Ross's do now he's going to schools and
do talks to people as well so all this
ties in but the fact that the CIA
you know we're led to believe that the
government are here to protect and serve
us but they were the ones who are
bringing in the cork in into the [__]
country and the Clintons were behind it
to be fair they protected the cocaine
they served it right up they've done a
good job good their chocolate yeah okay
a lot of these elite families their
money is based on drugs or a lot of it
has come from the drug trades and that
includes the royal family let me ask you
guys a question
yeah who do you think Jax is mate who do
you think the biggest drug dealer ever
in the history of the world was and this
person makes Pablo Escobar look like
small change and read the [__] eights
he had a lot of young mistress you know
what el chapo is it makes el chapo look
like small change come on then it's it's
someone royal right yeah it's I want to
hear I'm on the edge of my seat it's
wrong Queen Victoria really
oh boy yeah [__] yeah all my of the
British Army force the Chinese go to war
with the Chinese two times to force that
population to remain addicted to opium
FDR Roosevelt birth family are in the
mix as well in the opium trade Clinton
their family CIA bring in the cocaine
the money-laundering profit in from
cocaine all goes back peps teen
laundering the cocaine proceeds this is
what I'm saying
I didn't expect to reach these
conclusions I just wanted to write a
book on the war on drugs and I found
that the history of the world the elite
families a lot of their wealth has come
from the drug trade and some of these
are the same families that got up and
became presidents and fought this war on
drugs and locked up especially black
people for taking the same drugs they
were bringing into the country he had
much about the Rockefellers because
they're obviously an interesting yeah
watch videos videos on the Rockefellers
and read books about Queen Victoria just
to be clear screaming with all the
eighteen hundred's yeah Wow yeah I mean
biggest drug empire in the world the
British Empire the opium trade I suppose
so yeah it's like nothing public review
and sent my ships over yeah you don't
take my product he was aiming to get
he was at the submarine level yeah for
not the battle
so really it's what what your I think
and everyone sort of learns this from a
young age anyways it's either a lot of
people say like the government's a
racket racketeering thing anyway a lot
of people kick up against that but it's
only really now that people are really
putting the things together to almost
prove that sort of thing President
George HW Bush and Bill Clinton they go
up in front of the American public on TV
and just stone-faced lied about how much
they cared about this war on drugs and
how they were going to increase
sentences and a lot more people up for
the very product they were bringing in
the country but mental isn't it and
until this day you've got black guys not
this day so three on the free strikes
last in life sentences for the product
they brought in well I mean this leads
us back to what Sean was I think I'm the
first podcast when we met you you said
invest in weed because it's gonna be
good you think about pull down the years
who have been locked up because of just
because wheat and stuff like that and
now they come buy into it and legalize
the free strikes laws you've still got
guys doing life sentences for money on
that weed possession getting you locked
up yeah people say that's not right Sean
Google that and you will see free
strikes laws weed possession life
sentences you see it Wow
yeah it makes people I mean we have the
same thing when David Icke came on it
makes people quite nihilistic isn't it
because it makes you feel well what what
can you really do about all of this
yeah yeah yeah I start giving up really
it's nothing about [__] it that's not
our business
just worry about my own little life and
get on with it go for different phases
in the beginning when I first was
researching this I was disillusioned
it's like a lost faith in humanity
wanted to expose it and if I eat you up
that energy but you can expose it and
just get on with your life and
appreciate the good things but the world
has gotten to you in all of this
research that you're doing yet all of
this that you're putting out there we
had David Icke on last week we asked him
a question about like you know you're
uncovering all of these people
potentially like royal satanic [__]
pedo rings and you're you're touching
levels of society we as you've just said
one button pressed and then you just
disappear you know you ever thinking
about this as you're writing or as
you're speaking on your channel like
maybe I shouldn't [__] say this on my
end of [__] just disappearing into a
back of a van one day but that is a
genuine look like I'm not even just
saying that like I kind of worry about
you and that because you're you're
ringing people up now and you're pissing
people off potentially I don't have the
amount of followers like you guys have
got 300,000 subscribers pal Russell
Brand David Icke David is Russell Brand
into this sort of thing Russell Brand
was into it and I don't know if he got a
threaten the walk but he turned it down
a bit yeah I didn't notice that he was
doing his true news wasn't he yeah and
then it stopped and it was like he took
a sabbatical and came back anyone and
yeah he's gone is very different now
it's all about like does yeah he's
fantastic but I know you he was pressing
buttons and all of a sudden he was like
yeah I'm just gonna help people live
their lives a bit better and I was just
fine but it was a massive change of
direction yeah so what we're saying is
if all of a sudden you go on a break and
then you come back and just give
self-help tips you've been silenced yeah
look at the size of the following iyx
got it does world tours yeah and ike
safe isn't he I was in his house doing
the interview with him to him to be fair
though the wood doors are bulletproof
yeah what was it like meeting David
after I was in Mac security Madison
Street jail Arizona 2003 just been sent
upstairs and I'm just in this cell a
neighbor
don't even know the guy shoves a book
under my door it's the Alice in
Wonderland 9/11 one read not know if
it's just clicking you know from my own
experience as an options trader
everyone's clicking and then I started
to listen to Ike on the radio while I
was in prison on this show called coast
to coast of art Bell and gotten more of
his box sent in to me and just from like
being in awe of his work and then
actually seen him after watching his
videos when I got out and seeing him or
will you a bit starstruck when you met
you know when you see someone on TV and
then you actually meet him in person
and you get there's like a
something that does something funny to
your brain yeah there was that guy our
cat member his name now he was the
villain in the Rambo movies that was
trying to kill Sylvester Stallone and
when I saw him kill Ram Bosley I was
scared I got that reaction so when I saw
Ike it was I did you get that get the
reaction a little bit and when I was
talking to him you know I could I could
feel him like he was warming up but by
the second hour of the interview he was
on fire he was completely lit up and I
just felt this really good chemistry
with him like we could have just talked
for hours he was really he was very a
clearly found a kindred spirit in you
and I thought was a really sweet
interview because it's clay that you two
got a mutual said well you're both
researchers yeah he bought and it is a
special kind of person to spend the
length of time that you would just
absorbing that kind of information
absorbed all of his work right at the
interview and at the end when we heard
for a long time and I felt the wall he's
got a nice hug actually oh he's good
yeah but that's my question because I I
know you probably agree with him on 9/11
at etc but a lot of when we first say
we've had David icon I'm sure you got
the same thing of lizard people guy like
nothing because that's the headline that
everyone goes with what is your opinion
on that theory okay we are all complex
sets of beliefs and theories and
understandings and if you look at the
geniuses of the world and what they've
said and how people say look up to these
people and think yeah this white guy
said this there and it's brilliant and
it stood the test of time if you look at
all of the other things they've ever
believed you're gonna find things though
that are diametrically opposed to what
you believe so do you then dismiss what
somebody says because you don't believe
with another fraction of what they've
said mm-hmm you can't do that otherwise
you dismiss everything all knowledge it
would never come down throughout the
ages exactly so I believe and I'm
completely open-minded when I go into
this room and I believe in steering that
in the direction of the things that I'm
interested in that I believe in myself
or that I'm researching for that reason
I never asked him about it I just left
it because I thought there's so much
real hard facts that he's got to deliver
it's not the and I also what here comes
the headline doesn't it which you don't
really yeah I all sorted our audience to
just actually digest some of the stuff
that I think is approvable that he can
give us even if not all of it is
provable to make you wonder about um
sort of because he was talking about
belief systems in general does it make
you wonder about belief systems and kind
of are you a religious guy
well fascinated by belief systems yeah
so I read over a thousand books and just
under six years I read all of the
religious texts Koran which would you
think that's actually an honest question
which one if you would gravitate towards
one of them was there any one that you
thought would I had a penis is that what
I mean for me okay good
this might be cop-out but I'm an
observer I don't subscribe but you must
enjoy
you must get pleasure from some of you
what surprised me was what gave me
pleasure was noticing that all of the
same characters and all of the same
stories yeah we're in all of these book
the themes are the sins God the
immaculate conception has been going for
thousands of years the floods been going
through thousands of years they're all
just passed down to whatever religions
the leaders of that age want to
indoctrinate Society into so do you ever
because I thought sure I was telling
Ryan about the documentary zeitgeist and
that for me was like the first time I
ever got into conspiracy theory sort of
thing yeah but in that they talked about
around the world all the Immaculate
Conception story is told in every
society everywhere so Jesus isn't really
very original in that sense even looks
very similar to I'm pretty sure I was
watching a program where there was a
society that came before Christianity
who had the exact same looking day I
guess it was so anyway back to what you
have got because we're useless what do
you what did it make you think reading
all this though it blew my mind as
someone had been raised in a Catholic
school I'm in told that this was fact
that all of these characters were in all
of the same religious texts and will
worship by the religions predating
Christianity so I thought to myself okay
a lot of the religions say you've got to
believe this otherwise you're
you're not doing the right thing to get
to heaven or something you've seen that
effect yeah so if let's say there's like
ten major religions and they're all
saying we're a hey even if one of them
is right 90% is wrong so I'm just an
observing I'm not trying to disrespect
religion here because there's good and
bad in every belief system that's what
was my end conclusion look at all the
good work of Mother Teresa you know I
know people who are priests who do
brilliant work even though I've watched
the sins of my father and all these
other Doc's about the Catholic
pedophiles so I try and focus on the
good in people I try and focus on the
good in religions I try and focus on the
good in belief system does make you
happy I just make one damage of it's
sort of been you begin to be used for
these kind of ends of people like
Epstein and people at the top and
because religions changed a lot it's
probably faster than ever over the last
150 200 years people have mixed more or
there's not as people this is probably
the age where people have mixed most and
absolutely cold the other people around
them the least so in in the past if you
know we gone to another country we just
killed them all we weren't gone let's
help them rebuild
we'd you've just gone they're all dead
that's ours now well I mean there is
there is a still a lot of that going on
but yeah it's less than it's it's it
we're more accepting of other cultures
than we've ever been I mean [__] me just
come into London was an experience for
me you know that is also well the second
other country compared to Newcastle but
what is happening now is they are it
does feel weird like there is um they
are trying to change what religion is
doing now rather than make it a vehicle
for good it's not to become a bit more
of a political device it's starting to
become it's always been social control
yeah so when I say religion is good
things like I saw people come to prison
they got big sentences the suicidal and
they click up with the Christian crew
they find God as I yeah what this
prevents them from killing themselves
and gives them a purpose in prison and
then gives them a group to belong to and
feel something but then on the dark side
I had met a guy in prison he was from a
wealthy family he was the black sheep
and he was the black sheep because he'd
been molested by a Catholic priest and
he showed me all the legal paperwork on
this case
and in the Tucson area or this happened
the Catholic Church basically had a
house on every street because all people
the people were still leaving their
properties to the church in the belief
that they would get a place in heaven or
the church was encouraging these people
to go to Catholic I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry I love the father they go well
I'll just leave it in the Catholic
Church because then they'll reimburses
when I got on the other side I give them
this here and the Catholic Church was
encouraging them to go off to Catholic
ker homes to spend the rest of their
years in the meantime signing over the
house to the Catholics yeah that was the
11th commandment on it so sign your
house over and you'll get one in heaven
yeah that I'm sorry it's very hard to
not laugh you watch since my father is a
priest I haven't seen it so they tell
the victims that we are going to
discipline this guy you know this will
never happen again and all they do is
move in 20 30 miles away and the
families are letting him into his home
he's a Catholic priest he's not gonna
have my kids he's molesting hey Brian
can you describe your style in one word
probably powerful I like powerful
powerful a good word for you but a lot
of people out there don't have a word it
could be casual sophisticated maybe
playful that's where stiff but that's
where so stay shakes calm poured sighs
true comes in because we can help you
out
oh it's [__] fix these guys basically
personal stylists online right they look
at what you've got they look at what you
want to be and they go guys we can help
you out
well basically can go on the website and
they go hmmm this come out like this but
there's no minimum commitment is it like
Pinterest but for clothes kind of except
they're actually sending you stuff in a
box oh my god yeah her breasts or do
that yeah it's actually good that they
don't do that because stitch fix have
stepped in there's no commitment you
don't have to be like yeah I'm gonna
sign up forever [__] birth giver and
if you sign up with us at stitch fix
calm forward slash true you're
supporting the podcast you're not only
supporting the podcast don't you move
you can also get 25% off for your first
box basically so anything that comes in
that first box you get 25% off after
that
yeah plus a $20 styling fee so these
guys look at you they go sure this guy
could suit this he could sue this he
could suit this so get started today at
stitch fix comm forward slash true and
get an extra 25% off when you keep
everything in your box
what's that was absurd little 25%
probably 25% yeah
Takashi six nine I think at that point
I'm like okay you've been researching
this case as well which is a totally
different case but it's also really in
the media right now
and you're sort of the king of that at
the moment so he was part of the ninth
ray Bloods he was he was throwing up the
gang signs he was saying you know scum
gang in all his music and promoting them
but in reality you promote he seems to
have been to my knowledge a stupid
little boy who got caught up in some
big-time dealers yeah so I did
that's a Kashi 69 playlist last year
because people were interested
he had a RICO case people don't
understand what that meant I think we
did the clip as well really predicate
result is called it's a it's a
conspiracy case where you've got a bunch
of co-defendants like I mentioned ABCDE
earlier arm so I had my conspiracy case
all of the different co-defendants so he
was in there got arrested and now
they're telling him you got weapons
offenses you got drug offenses this is a
big criminal organization nine trade
Bloods you're looking at 47 years and
now looking back we see from the
paperwork from his testimony that he did
roll over quite quickly and agree to 24
hours isn't wicked to be fair it was
[__] kidnap by the guys he was up
against so I kind of understand but I
think the old get what they deserve here
this is if he went yeah yeah but there's
a blood in blood out packed with these
gangs if you're gonna roll on them and
you're gonna get up on the stand and
send
shotty and all these other guys down on
big sentences for the rest of your life
you've got Kos you've got kill on sight
shot Lee was the guy who if people don't
remember when needed The Breakfast Club
interview this guy was brought in to at
one point speak on his behalf and sort
of verify him as a gang member
and it seems as if a lot they were
managing him and taking a lot of his
money that should have been his and not
only did they kidnap him they robbed him
in broad daylight and basically made a
complete mug out of him while he
promoted them so but he is taking a huge
risk here in interning I mean they
turned on him first but he he's now I
don't know what has he got an
alternative to what he's doing really it
feels like there's a gun to his head
regardless all right if you sign up for
that lifestyle and you're putting hits
out on people which Takashi was it was
yeah yeah I mean that is class one
felony level so it's like they've caught
he said that he's another one I
interviewed on the podcast he said I
carry around with me whatever weapon I
know I can do the time for and my
preferred choice is knuckle dusters I'm
not just gonna pull out a gun and shoot
someone and end up in prison for the
rest of my life I know if I knock
someone out of my knuckledusters I'm
gonna do the time for it if the cashy
6:9 is putting hits out on people the
murder level yeah and then he's just
gonna roll over in prison that would be
called a [__] move he's sending
everybody else down so will happen you
just kick Kos Kos yeah he's gonna have
chaos for the rest of his life Kos now
he's being so stupid because he wanted
to promote himself and live that
lifestyle and be the guy as I do this
like he'll it really says that in his
court and his lyrics and then as soon as
it's getting serious
he's just bitched out but do you think
he'll survive it if if they let him out
event all as this witness protection
this point cuz it's even witness
protection it's not like you can hire
him in a you know hire him in a
supermarket have him sucking shells like
the tattoos really give it over tattoos
naba gent I mean he is so recognizable
now he's a superstar he watched the
movie Black Mass no you know about that
gangster that movie was about the Irish
his name now well I first thought of
Goodfellas because obviously Henry hit
lap Mass Henry Hill [__] Henry Hill
went down a Goodfellas testified and
then eventually saw this story later on
down the line but it's not later you
can't do that
your Takashi's explain that the whole
world knows what you lost in black mass
he was in the prison system supposed to
be protected Irish of them James Bulger
Bulger Whitey Bulger yeah so why am
Johnny Depp in the film yeah so whitey
balls you ends up getting moved around
the prison system to a place where the
Murphy finally caught up with him and
took him out so I don't know how strong
and how tight the ninth ray Bloods are
across the country and how you know
Father tentacles reach but if he gets
put in witness protection for example
they were like Marley's tattoos on his
face how's he gonna hide yeah there
weren't Bloods in the sense of like West
Coast Bloods thought it was like the New
York it was a specific sort of it seems
quite a small group but it's a prison
gang which is heavy yeah because the
people running the prison gangs are the
people perhaps doing life for murders
and stuff like that they don't play
around they've got nothing left to lose
yeah yeah but he's got nothing left to
lose and he took the old 10 but he
wasn't liked well it was either life in
prison or snitch and have some sort of
life all right they say it's life in
prison in the beginning but then if you
all hang tight and have a united defense
like we discussed in the other clip that
we did the prostate in the beginning is
saying you guys all face it live because
they know domino effect if one Falls
they all fall like that was what
happened is some in the balls case a
couple years before mine or 57 agreed to
cooperate in my case everybody hung
tight only four agreed to cooperate over
100 it wasn't enough so you know I
accepted that and signed for nine and a
half years on my plea bargain and did my
time I got I'm a bit they've got they've
got a lot of evidence on 69 that's the
one thing they do oven and you're saying
if they hung tight if they had a hung
tight I think Takashi six nine could
have got it down so anywhere from five
to twenty years and he wouldn't have had
to do that whole amount right but the
one thing is to to be fair to the guy
that one of the main reasons is they
[__] robbed in Blaine and they're
kidnapped him and beat the [__] out of
him pretty much it seems like so
he seemed scared all right so I had
people in my organization who testified
against me and people said a lot you
know are you mad at these people except
for doing these things to you and I said
no I take responsibility for choosing
my association with those people that
was my decision so whatever contact
consequences arise after I make that
decision that's on me he chose to be in
the mix of people he knew were running a
drug gang and conspiracy to murder
operation so he's got to accept he's a
child he's a
I mean he's 23 but he's acting like a
child who just has not thought through
any of this at all and now it's getting
real and he's like [__] this it's for
the rest of his life he's no-win
situation do you think he can ever get
out and remake music and go back alright
even he's pointing the finger a little
bit of cardi B and he's probably figure
a lot it do you remember Jim Jones he's
really just said like he was the [__]
retired rapper he literally just
released an album all right so there was
two co-defendants didn't sign plea
bargains but went to trial that caused
two squashy to have to get up in court
and give testimony under oath
he's already corporate against all the
others they've signed the plea bargains
on just on what he said on write on the
record work with the with the cops so by
doing that now you know he it's it's Kos
niche category for the rest of his life
there's no coming back from mmm but
Henry Hill for example and we're talking
real mafia oh yeah in like the Mafia
he snitch on everyone that for those who
don't know the guy who Goodfellas is
about lived the rest of his life oh they
never came from yeah so they only just
got Whitey Bulger and Henry Hill was a
low-level associate yeah but he sent a
lot of them down though that was one of
the thing that you know I mean so yeah
but you know look how long it took for
him to catch up with Bulger yes Sammy
the bull they've not caught with him yet
he's back out now he got released and
you had contact with him he was my
competitor in the ecstasy market are his
people took my top sales guy they
enticed him to a nightclub in Scottsdale
under the pretext of doing a drug deal
and knocked his teeth out Sammy Duvall
Shawn told me in prison he'd been
dispatched one night to kidnap me from a
nightclub and take me out to the desert
so Sammy the ball he sent down John
Gotti the Teflon Don and hundreds of
other pin is funny right against because
I asked you questions like are you not
worried that you're going to be have a
hit put out on you and I totally forget
that you've lived their life that it's
follow
risk yeah I almost I almost divided
Shawn from that life to shore nose yeah
a youtuber yeah and I forget that like
you literally did nine it's funny
because a lot of youtubers are just sort
of like you know they they put out their
little social hits on people they try
and cancel people I think we put Shawn
in that category weirdly and now and
then actually though Shawn's lived a lot
of life yeah similar myself you had a
real life and you've actually had way
even one of the few people I've met who
have had more of a life and and for the
record I hate those Khonsu try and
cancel people in terms of everybody I'm
on good terms with the G dog and the New
Mexican Mafia people yeah how many of
them reached out you from the park yeah
G Duggars reached out G dog was the guy
who taught me over to meet his brothers
and they had my back cuz we protect the
G dog I believe I told you that story
were yeah he pulled out the cop on the
gun yeah because the cop walks in the
house I can smell weed nobody move and G
dogs like the only one who's not moving
leaving his you [__] and we all
run off into the night yeah foxy and I
just met the met the guy yeah he jumps
into an apartment nearby that we've got
and because we protected him he says me
and my brothers have got your back go
over the brothers house they've got the
rocket-propelled grenade launcher on the
TV and a guy who's on a killing spree
swings a spoon full of coke in my face
so snort this you know cuz they want to
see from an undercover couple or
whatever but a couple years later
they're all headline news at that house
all busted all her photos heads of the
New Mexican Mafia and it was G dog who
had my back man he was one of my
bodyguards when I was doing the rave
stuff and G dog is still in touch
there's no there's no beef there there's
no frets Sammy the Bulls people they've
gone to Hollywood with Mob Wives
there's no fret stuff so I don't burn my
bridges I've not testified against
anyone and these people you know don't
don't view me as however since then the
way you tell your story could be
perceived by some bad people as
snitching because like there's song
lyrics where rappers of said [__] which
is be like 50 cent had a song
where he you know he said things that
had happened and people said yo he
snitched cuz he said things you're doing
a form of art right now where you're
telling your story and implicating
people and saying what happened that
could be taken badly if you go into the
prison system right away
pedophiles RKOs kill on sight so if you
snitch against any criminal are you a
snitch if you snitch against a pedophile
organization if you're putting it out
there but people I'm talking about that
but I think I would get a pass for this
stuff no you get a pass for this I'm
talking about some of the other stories
that you've told are you ever worried
about you know where you like the story
you've just told my pulling a gun on a
cop and stuff like that alright soft
change his name to G dog okay because
he's not going to get in trouble for
every dog all the stories I've told
names have been carefully changed check
you know I'm well the real name is AMI
yeah that was an interesting edit how
long will we be going now Robin an hour
and 45 yeah yeah okay I've got a
question for you guys yeah shoot not
literally when you interview when you
interview a person yeah do you get huge
backlash is when you interview certain
people like people start threatening you
guys just because you've interviewed
that person some so remember threatening
threatening 40-minutes threat just to
clarify what do you mean by hey
someone's come on is controversial for
example yeah that's got a belief system
different to you guys maybe yeah and
then people are yeah we heard that word
Bilzerian know else we had you remember
early on when we got some of the drug
users on yeah so we had a friend of
yours who was a heroin addict I forgot
his name off the top of my head he was
the West Ham lad who when I went into
schools the leg he does a lot of school
talks as well I'm sure you've more
Hannaford's I warned ya what a lovely
guy he was but III think I think we had
a few people saying oh you're
glamourizing drug use or what we we got
told that we were a portal a portal to
drugs are a gateway to drugs a gateway
to I mean maggots in your legs gonna
wonder gosh
everyone gets that shirt after a while I
think people realize so we and I we
always use this an example like when we
had what's that was the [__] guy who
came on the comedian with comedian he
was on snapchat idiot [__]
Essex guy dapper laughs I like dollar
high quite I quite like to use a bit of
it take it at the time he's done some
[__] thing since um I think
ultimately the Azorean so yeah I'm sure
I mean yeah we weren't for dinner with
him afterwards or I am anyway I think
you might be fighting on that so I tried
to absolutely nail him and I know them
but some people got quite angry about it
I'm like why you trying to turn this and
afterwards I realized if you give people
enough if you basically let people on
say what they want to say people make
their own conclusions and that happened
recently damn Bilzerian didn't it well
yeah I got a bit of grief because of the
way he was speaking about women and I
think some of our female subscribers
weren't happy with that and I felt a bit
like oh like because I make jokes about
everything and and sometimes I make like
meals chauvinist jokes but I'm from a
place in any I'm from an era I you know
working offshore where you say certain
things where you don't actually mean it
literally and I think sometimes being
sarcastic and making a joke about women
and making a joke about the people who
make a joke about women that's the real
job I'm making sometimes gets lost with
some people and they're like well you
said this and so yeah I was actually
doing parody of the people who would say
that I felt that what you know we didn't
come off a bit cold
yeah and they blame you the interviewer
I don't know I mean I'm sure you're
aware of it now you're doing a lot of
interviews yourself mate is that the one
thing that the one thing I mean I don't
I I don't mean this as a knock towards
my audience and and like when people
come up to me in the street there is a
lovely feeling like I've had people come
to see how you've helped me through bad
times and you've done this onions on its
site at that very moment I absorb that
energy and go [__] me god I feel like
I've made a difference in this kid if it
feels [__] fantastic but on a day to
day basis if I worried about what anyone
thinks to me I mean [__] hell how
would I even make an interview I
wouldn't get through a footprint
a minute are genuinely I treat the hair
and the love pretty much the same like I
just go thanks for watching that's all
I'm you know as long as people are
watching that's my job and you can't let
it get you you've just got to follow
your own vision and say what you think
and at the time and not worry about what
any and generally you are a good person
so when you speak it's usually going to
be from a good place in it yeah yeah
don't shoot the interviewer yeah I'm
sure you've had a bit of [__] how is it
has anyone in particularly in a rough
ride or something like that oh there's
been a few situations on the channel
where they blame you for well you know
some dodgy characters so I'm sure you've
had them I'm rebuilding the biggest
network of gangsters across the UK right
now through this true crime I love the
fact that they're all hooking up through
showing you like bigger deals photos I
mean yeah in general I think platforming
indie platform you know that is probably
not a very effective way of looking
you're you're hitting the level of Fame
right now where you're hitting like
towards 300,000 is that right yeah
thanks to you guys man
no and it's all the videos that you're
in the graph that you're doing because
I've seen saw I've seen youtubers who I
think if you just put the work and you'd
be out of sight and they don't put the
work and you are putting that working
surely you're hitting a point where now
you can't do certain play are you when
you do go certain places it's just like
everyone [__] knows you and that sort
of thing you do a lot of school talks
for example I was gonna say if Sean was
a prominent pedophile it'd be [__]
what what is it like so cuz when I when
did I first want true Jordy hmm after
you've heard that first podcast in every
single school I went into it was I've
seen you on the true Jordy I've seen you
on the true Jordy that schools need okay
but now people random people do come up
to me on the streets and say I've seen
your YouTube videos yeah and you're very
noticeable as well you don't look like
at any like any guy chin and I mean
you've got a look distinguishing yeah
you're right
like yeah I'm recognizable got a lot
like Nosferatu I was expecting one of us
to make a joke there showing you yeah so
I'm just wondering how it affected your
day-to-day life you know I mean it's a
you know has it changed in any way or
maybe pretty much it's not getting
recognized enough unfortunately pretty
much full-time Shawn Howard now so all
my content was in litchi form all of
those books I had that content I didn't
understand and so I went on your show
that there was a demand for my stories
in video form so I already had 10 years
of content right so all I've done is
took that content well in the beginning
before the true-crime podcast and put it
out on video form and let's just help
the channel grow yeah cuz lads don't
want to read books I didn't want to read
it but when I was a kid yeah I'm not
much of a reader I mean I saw I really
feel like a dumb [__] when I say that
but I'm just I'm too ADHD I I'm always
like I need things that I can do like if
I'm playing the computer I put you're
thinking I'm generally mean for example
yeah so with is there a movie happenin
yet because in my head I looked at your
life story and I think what a [__]
movie that would me yeah there's a guy
flying out from America really good guy
and I've been working with him for a
couple of years now but I can't see
anything more than that because it'd be
careful I want to say though is I know
some lawyers I could put you in touch
with a good entertainment lawyer yeah
because I've known for example in the
yaris who we had on who did fear of 30
even with Netflix he feels like he got
[__] over we also got a friend in
common the guy who did the Thailand
fighting he feels like he got [__]
over so let's make sure a whoever plays
you they're gonna have to be really
something you don't get [__] over you
know yeah because they did it on agency
it I've got agents mmm yeah I've got a
really good agent with United agents
have been working with for years I'm
great I would look forward to seeing
that I either want to see it as a movie
or I think I feel like it's almost like
a ten-part Netflix series as oh don't be
yeah yeah or even Matt let's be honest
but the other [__] that we've heard you
could turn that you'd do like everything
yeah this could be serious HBO
I hear HBO knocking thanks for coming on
me huge thanks to all the subscribers
all the new subscribers all the true
Jodi army
yeah really feel all your love and
support man every day I go eat my
breakfast and read the comments Oh
Malcolm I try to avoid comments sure
you've been fantastic as all and good
luck on the future and I really do hope
that we see the movie or Netflix series
or whatever happens of your lifestyle
take everything to the next level
switcher covers off we're not gonna find
out Sean's a great after-dinner speaker
by the way I think it's worth saying
that he'd be I think she'll make a great
oh he's a great public speaker got 12
bucks an Amazon links in the description
box below this video and I'm available
to do talks across the country exactly
brilliant
all right thanks for watching everyone
don't forget to hit that like button
stay subscribed and we will see you
later